[Applaudissements]
la première chose que je dois faire
c'est de vérifier que personne n'a
d'oreillettes et que les oreilles sont
profs vous avez raison ça c'est très
très important
moi je viens pour les oreillettes
présent les propres c'est clair net et
précis
que ce soit clair parce que j'avais
besoin aujourd'hui on a parlé etc
mais là où mais par souci d'équité
jean-luc suis désolé j'étais obligé
qu'est ce que c'est que ça rien on est
on est là le premier qui a épuisé son
capital temps bien évidemment a perdu ok
on va commencer par christian bien
évidemment puisque c'est le maître de
midi
alors ici c'est challenge alors alors
jean-luc mais juste je peux dire un truc
aussi les pats midi il n'y a pas de m
moi je veux bien mais alors on commence
par question parce que c'est l'invité
une voie là à les inviter
si vous êtes prêt en régie pour les
chronomètres il ya soixante secondes
question est ce que vous êtes bourrel je
suis très janvier
on envoie le bonjour à tout le monde
bien évidemment et bonjour à tous et on
embrasse l'homme est bon jeu il a
toujours été les grecs ses adversaires
et tu lui as rien répondu jean luc bon
jeu parce que moi j'ai pas les
branchements fou
[Rires]
première question
alors je dis juste enrichi jeudi top à
chaque fois pour et quand on demande à
bonne réponse le chronomètre s'arrête on
est prêt et tu vas voir ce que c'est de
faire un jeu sur s'est vite tu vas
comprendre mes chronos qui s'arrêtent
pas de facture il va comprendre mais
c'est important par souci effectuera des
kits et ça n'est pas la question
devant le silence s'il vous plaît
monsieur hanouna christian de quel pays
vient d'une voiture qui porte la lettre
d l'allemagne est bonne réponse alors
déjà effectivement ça règle seconde
frère et où une seconde déjà il ya une
seconde à mon époque quand j'animais
cette émission c'est 40 secondes
attention soyez plus rapide quand il dit
l'allemagne donc l'éviter que c'était à
57 et repassage antilles c'est pas grave
c'est une seconde pour toi jean le cam
jean luc top qui est le président de la
république d'italie depuis le 3 février
2015 sa phase sérgio matarelle là qui
chantait tout doucement en 1981 serbie
bibi bonne réponse à l'arrière partie 50
56 ha tiens tiens 55,6 un tiens si tu
commence à flipper bébé qu'on fait et
lui le dauphin aux cherry bomb question
tu fais ce que tu sais mon niveau
les fans n'ont pas de toi que tu vas
être avec nous alors 5 ans